there was one other issue on the the
Brett Bear interview that I wanted to
show you because there was this new uh
crime bill that Trump is pushing now and
and Brett got him caught up in something
I'll explain a little bit more on the
other side
as an example
a woman who you know very well
was in jail she had 24 more years to
serve she served for 22 years she had
Thomas Johnson Alice she was in the
Super Bowl high quality oh yeah
I said how many years and she was on a
telephone call and they were involved in
selling marijuana mostly marijuana
and she got like 50 years in jail but
she'd be killed under your plan huh as a
drug dealer no no no under my oh under
that uh it would depend on the severity
it would depend on the sad and she's
technically a former drug dealer she the
she had multi-million dollar cocaine
ring and a drug dealer look so even
Alice Johnson in that ad she can't do it
okay by the way if
that was there no she wouldn't be killed
it would start as of now so you wouldn't
go yes you're not going to retroactively
kill Alice Johnson now but the point is
the criminal Bill Criminal Justice
Reform Bill he's pushing now would have
this woman killed she was not only
marijuana by the way she was a cocaine
dealer okay fine
I can put it aside when anyone thinks
about drugs and crack and all the rest
of it but he's touting this bill that
would have killed the very that he wants
the bill now
would have killed the very woman I met
Alice Johnson actually at the Trump
Hotel in DC two or three days later
after she was led out of jail she was
with a whole bunch of her friends I was
having dinner with uh with Candace
Candace Owens and Clay Travis and we
went up to them and we chatted and she
was a lovely woman sure she sold a
little cocaine okay nobody's perfect but
the point is Trump's new bill would have
her kill and he didn't even know that
like when he's like ah well well
guys the reason I'm trying to do all
this is not to relentlessly hit Trump I
I don't find it fun I I actually don't
find it fun like sometimes it's kind of
silly and he makes it sort of easy with
with the nonsense
um but we have to push the Endless Lies
out that's what I'm saying we don't
expect everything to be perfect we don't
expect everything to be all truthful all
the time or anything else but right now
the left and the corporate media and all
of it runs on nothing other than live
and and a whole bunch of us can see that
and that's why more people are waking up
in red pilling and everything else right
I get the messages from you guys every
day on that but then on the other side
if this is what Trump's going to do
rewriting history and DeSantis is evil
and Florida is evil and they're not
knowing what the bills are that he's
putting forward and being confused about
where classified documents were with his
personal stuff and all the stuff like
the lying the just the endless lying has
to stop but if you disagree with me on
that particularly on the Trump side I
want to hear from you I want to hear why
you think endless lying in the quest for
power is okay like do the ends justify
the means I don't think so I don't think
so but I know some people do
[Music]
foreign